oh there we have to start all over again
so good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to our planning committee
meeting today i can assure you i am glad
to be back
we have three applications to consider
along with the reports on planning
appeals and the section 106 agreements
just a reminder that the section 106
agreement will be an exempt item so that
when we could come to it any public
still in the room will be asked to leave
and the live stream on youtube will be
ended
and just for your information we have
two speakers this afternoon and they
will be for our final application
moving on item one apologies for absence
uh none have been received here
thank you
item two declarations of interest
uh again none have been received here
thank you
we've been through this item three
minutes of the last meeting
can i have someone to move and support
them thank you councillor armitage
a seconder
councillor browse thank you
all those in favor
any abstentions
[Music]
thank you
the motion has been carried
the main business for the afternoon
is the application set before us i would
like the clerk to explain for the
benefit of members speakers and those
watching on youtube how we will deal
with them
yes thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the applications this afternoon
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received
since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and how hard copies
have been circulated to you
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
after this the chair will ask the
speakers to address the meeting
there are two speakers on the final
application at matlock farm
each of the speakers will have three
minutes to put forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions if necessary
to clarify any points they have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on the application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and determination by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
after a speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
they will be allowed to remain in the
chamber
but they will not be allowed to
participate further from that point
similarly the speaker who will
participate by zoom may continue to view
the meeting but they must remain muted
and turn their cameras off so that they
too play no further part
as you are aware this meeting is being
live streamed and a recording will be
placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy it
thank you chair
thank you we'll move to the first item
this afternoon which is the application
for ashover ned4
22 forward
zero zero two four eight fl
and it's a section 73 application to
revise condition two on approved
drawings to application twenty four
slash zero 000 79 fl on land at cropton
vale orton little more ashover
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning manager to
tell us about any late comments reports
that have been produced and to give a
brief presentation showing any photos
and plans of this site
i will allow the officers to complete
the presentation consequently members
could you please reserve any points of
order or questions
about the process to the end thank you
thank you chair i'm grateful to alice
for help with the the presentation chair
just before we go through the slides
just to
advise members first of all in respect
of the late comments report that was
issued yesterday
and secondly chair two
advised members this is an application
as you say under section 73 seeking to
retain some minor amendments to the
approved scheme and so bearing in mind
that fallback position chair officers
are recommending that the scheme is
approved and subject to the relevant
conditions and if i just ask alice now
to
move through the presentation please if
you could
move to the first
slide alice please thank you the
application site chairs you can see out
outlined and then colored in
a beige color you recall at the last
meeting an application to
retain an as-built garage at the site to
joining this was considered an approved
and that is in the area that's gray just
to the left-hand side of the the beige
area but that is a different application
site different application
this application before this afternoon
will stand on its own merits chair but
the center of that beige area is the
building that is the subject of the
application if alice can just move on
please
the application site outlined in red as
you can see at the center of the red
area there is the building that's
subject to the application it's
partially constructed but is seeking to
retain an alteration to that scheme
originally approved primarily an
increase in the height of the the ridge
of the roof by approximately 600
millimeters
thank you chair
sorry 200 millimeters apologies if you
move on alice please
just in terms of the the detailing on
the
right hand side of this slide is the
scheme that was originally submitted for
consideration
back in 2020 and the slides on the
left-hand side show the scheme as sought
to be retained you can see there are
some some limited changes but primarily
the difference is in the increase in the
height of the roof and we'll see that in
a second you can just move on to the
next slide alice please
showing the other two elevations and
particularly if you can bear in mind the
the roadside
elevations which is the eastern
elevation and we'll come back to that in
a second
analysis if you just move on please
the
slide now shows the the cross sections
and were approved as part of the
application back in 2020 you can see at
the top
element there
what was was improving you'll see in a
second that the two gable elements in
particular
noticeably taller which is
primarily the main element that's taller
than approved but you can also see the
two upper floor windows on the front
elevation there four paned whereas
they are actually constructed as six
paned
again now let's see if you can move on
please
and then on the the roadside elevation
the outline at the top there is the
scheme that was referred to in the
decision notice it's largely actually
unchanged in terms of the detailing that
was approved again you'll see that in a
second but again with the increase in
the height of the ridge of the roof
and we just got two or three photos
chair further to the site visit of
yesterday
don't want to go through all those
slides but that is the the front
elevation as constructed
analyst please
a roadside elevation showing that that
eastern elevation as you can see there
and then finally just as a reminder from
yesterday chair a longer view back
towards the site you can just see the
as built dwelling just above the the
wall there in the middle of that
photograph just the top
left of the bale of hay
thank you chair
thank you
we've got no speakers on this
application so i will move straight to
members if there's any questions for
adrian
no this is going very quickly
i can then open it to debate if there is
going to be a debate
would you like me to uh read the um
rules as regards motions chad yes please
uh thank you uh please bear to mind
members that a motion must be moved and
seconded before a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by the evidence as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations false or in other words
it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or a
different course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
in terms of the timings of the motions
they should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard read and
discussed the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached and will then invite
motions to be
put members will be reminded of this by
the clerk
if they wish to propose a motion before
then thank you chair
thank you well obviously there is no uh
debates we've moved to the motion has
any counselor earlier
thank you seconded by councillor cooper
all those in favour
that's been carried thank you
[Music]
move on to item two
of the application
this is the killer marsh proposed
conversion of an existing stable block
into a three-bedroom dwelling
resubmission on application
four slash
two zero four slash zero zero three six
four fl these are the amended plans
this application number is ned for slash
twenty one forward slash zero zero nine
six nine zero
and i'll hand it over to you
thank you chair
and just if i can
ask alice to
bring up the presentation
just before we go through that chair
just again to
as members in respect to the late
comments report that was
sent out yesterday and also chair just
two vice members this application seeks
consent to convert an existing stable
block in which we'll see some slides in
a second into a dwelling house that
would be
used in association with the stables and
the horse culture that takes place on
the land surrounding it the application
share lies within the green belt
and your policies do allow for the
conversion of buildings in the green
belt subject to various criteria that
are set out in the report in this
instance
there is an alteration to the height of
the building and this is the 600
millimeters that i referenced earlier in
respect to this building so there is
some slight change but again discussion
of that issue and officers conclusions
on it in respect of impact on openness
of the green belt is set out in the
report
there have been no technical issues
chair that would lead officers to
conclude otherwise and so we're
recommending that permissions granted
for the scheme in its submitted form
and if i can ask alice to oh sorry alex
thank you the application site in this
instance chair again the site outlined
in the beige color
you can see it's accessed via a long
existing track
to
another track which you saw at the the
site visit yesterday which in turn
joins with boiler lane to the south
the building is in situ and we'll see
that if you can move on alice please
it's the most northerly of the pink
buildings with the other pink buildings
the other structures that exist on the
site which use for a variety of horse
related
storage and
horse accommodation they're all as i say
already existing as is the building
subject to the application
if you move on to the next
slide alice please
the green belt boundary runs to the east
of the site it runs along that the track
that is to the west of the
blue houses that form killer marsh
itself
the struct the subject of the
application is the building
colored in green on the slide on the
right hand side and the area to the
immediate right of there would be the
area of garden associated with the
dwelling house the turning area and
turning
t that's shown on there is the
turning um circles that have been
submitted to show that refuse vehicles
can access and leave the site
to the north of the
upper run of black dots is the public
footpath referred to and again we saw um
views what they are back into the site
from there at the site was it yesterday
but i believe there may be a slide of
that as a reminder this afternoon
thank you alice
so the existing structure you can see
there an existing run of stables that is
is authorized is in place and then if
you can move on to the next slide alice
please
showing the proposed conversion
and
you'll see from that there is the
limited raising in the height of the
roof to create a slightly sharper pitch
to the roof but otherwise the existing
openings and structure is retained and
converted
thanks alice
that's the structure that's in place
the gray area to the hand side of the
photograph is the existing minority
that's
on site and the area to the immediate
front of the photographer here the
grassed area is there it would be used
in connection with the dwelling as its
immediate curtilage you can see to the
right hand side again as we saw
yesterday
the tree backdrop to the site and beyond
that beyond another track is the public
footpath that
runs to the north of the site and
referenced in the report
thanks alice
and this is just a view back
um towards the site
for what it um what it shows this is
from the public footpath and you can see
in the foreground to the left the the
hedgerow that runs along
the majority of the footpath and back
towards the site
and it's difficult to see the site
itself and the building that's in situ
because of the drop in levels that we we
saw yesterday but the site does lie just
beyond and to the left of that tall tree
that's in the middle of the photograph
thanks alice
and i think this is the final shot this
is a view back towards the site proper
which is just
below the the tall single tree in the
very center of the photograph and it
shows the existing track that currently
runs from the other track then to boiler
lane this runs back towards the site
itself so that's the
setting of the site i think that may be
the the final photograph of alice yes it
is
thank you chair
thank you and again we've no speakers
for this application so any questions
for
adrian
councillor foster then councillor hall
thank you chair
my question is around the policy uh ss10
on this
look on page 23
7.1 and 7.2
uh
it looks like it's on the same footprint
and the mppf
states that extensions or alterations to
a building are not deemed inappropriate
provided they do not result in
disproportionate additions over and
above the size of the original building
so my question is uh
it's
do not consider it uh disproportionate
this actual uh this change from where it
is now although it's on the same
footprint it to me does look
disproportionate on the surface so just
perhaps a little bit of a clarity on
that please and i know it's also in
relation to ss9 as well that's where we
link into that if that's clear thank you
yes in officers opinion the
the extensions in this instance aren't
considered
um disproportionate and we would
consider them proportionate
in this instance um it does entail the
the raising of the roof but in terms of
the way that the building is is
constructed and the way that the current
roof pitch lies the office of view is
that it is a fortunate edition
but members will need to take a view on
that absolutely
counselor hall
thank you yeah hi adrian a couple of
things um
is there i've tried looking through the
paperwork are there any main services
going to the site you know either gas
electric or water do you know that
please
i don't offhand chair i'd need to check
the the records in respect to that okay
thank you the other question i've got
here is
from like we've got the um
proposal description it says
resubmission of
uh
2364 planning application and when we
look at that
it says refuse that planning application
was refused for on policy gs2 and ss10
which
counselor foster has already talked
about so
is they
obviously before it was a two-story
application this is a single story so is
do you feel that's sufficient for you to
um
recommend granting it that it's gone
from a two-story to single-story
proposal
yes yeah that that i think that's um
a good point that council hall raises
yes in in the first instance because of
the
scale of the proposals officers took the
view that a two-story unit was not
proportionate either in terms of
extension or in terms of its impact on
openness and the scaling back of the
extension the limited extension officer
opinion and the
retention of the primarily single-story
structure and its essence is is what's
led officers to change our view on the
application that's that's exactly the
the change that has led officers to take
a different view
councillor jones
i'm still concerned about the services
because i know somebody has
been writing in quite worried about the
fact that at the moment they use
generators which are quite noisy and i
think um we need to know that those
services are going to be there really
okay i'm just checking the the
application form
now just in respect to those elements
just to see if it provides me with the
information excuse me
the um foul sewage would be disposed of
to a septic tank chair
i don't have details in respect to the
the water provision on site but
when i've been on site it's clearly
water available to be
provided for the animals that are on the
site
but i don't can't see the other details
in
this instance chair but the fact that
the the applicant has sought consent for
dwelling house would lead me to the
conclusion that they have sort the
answers to those questions and can
provide the necessary provision of
facilities
any other questions council elliot
thank you chad
adrian again it's um it's a clarity
thing just like counselor foster and
it's around the same thing on 7.3
i'm just a little bit um
iffy about is is this outside the
settlement development limit i know it's
in greenbelt but is it outside the
settlement limits
yes it is it is yes and
on i don't want to fall foul of their
local plan because there's normally a
lot of hard workers into them local
plans as well
so i'm reading the last bit of seven
three
uh
talking about um the conversion of
buildings is okay providing the
already of substantial and permanent
construction
and capable of conversion without the
need for major alteration adaptation or
reconstruction
surely a stable to a dwelling
it's not just about the
the pitch of the roof i accept it's not
going to be imposing in that
scene in that in that situation
but what would you consider
that the alteration adaptation and
reconstruction to be if that's not huge
to make a dwelling
and service as part of it as well is it
going to be is it going to be gas is it
going to be lpg are they taking electric
gas and water onto site again from
somewhere else there's not a great deal
of detail on that for me
just in terms of the
alterations
proposed chair
the
issue that members need to consider is
uh exactly as council fosters said and
the policies are in themselves clear
that you should be
considering the
conversion of the building against
whether there is that major alteration
adaptation or
reconstruction so that that's the number
of what you need to consider and then
additionally in as
councillor foster's
referenced you need to consider what
impact if any there is on the openness
of the green belt and in terms of the
appropriate or inappropriate nature of
the development just taking the first
element first in terms of the
the conversion the the structural survey
that accompanied the application does
state that it is capable of conversion
and that it is of
a construction that would take that
conversion without significant
alteration so that's that's the view
that we've followed on from his officers
in terms of the the roofing
you would need to take a view first of
all whether that is
a major alteration
and as far as officers have concerned as
we set out in the report in this
instance because of the nature of the
roof and the potential for a new roof
structure often in conversions we
believe in this case as that's the only
alteration we consider that would meet
your policy tests
and the discussion i've just had with
cows to foster in respect of the impact
on the green belt would be also an
assessment you'll need to take as a
committee whether you think that
alteration
has
an impact on the openness again because
the conversion is now limited to a
single story unit and the increase in
height is that 600 millimeter level
officers have taken the view because of
the constraints of the site the way the
existing buildings set into the land and
the backdrop and the site specifics in
this instance there isn't that impact on
openness
just just finely share in terms of the
the services
so the that information isn't set out on
the application form but i
love the the opinion if the applicants
have sought consent for the
conversion of the dwelling as such they
can provide the necessary services to
provide that that normal requirements
for it for a dwelling house i'm sorry i
don't have any more details on that
thanks chad and thanks adrian
well i agree i i don't think there's a
huge impact with the with how it's set
out and how it's set into the the trees
and the ground i i agree with you
councillor foster
uh thank you chair uh staying on the
same vein and without doing it to death
uh mr kirkham but looking at a different
policy uh sdc one and page one two three
of the local plan
which is quoted in page 23
of the papers
and the actual definition under sdc1 b
they are structurally sound and capable
of reuse without major alterations
adaptations or reconstruction
and i think it
for myself this application is it's
based around how we interpret those
those three descriptions
and i know you've given some already and
i don't want to press you too much
further but if i can ask for a bit more
clarity on what you think
uh without attending to a debate chair
but just advice for from offices on that
major alterations adaptations and
reconstruction what normally comes
within that i get that it's only 600 mil
higher
the ridge it's
still
at just one floor
we're on the same footprint
but as regards the other changes to the
actual property
you know how can you provide a bit more
clarity on that please
the the way that that i personally
approach these
things chair is to try and understand
what amount of the building would be
retained so that's what how i approach
them and often in some of the debates
we've had
around in in this chamber we've talked
about new openings new alterations
element
what amount of the wall that would be
retained etc
and in this instance the remainder of
the structure is is pretty much going to
be retained with the existing openings
used so in terms of the structural
survey information that we have and the
details of the
drawings it would be my conclusion that
the vast majority of the other four
walls would be retained as they are to
comprise
that conversion
it's often the case that new roofing is
required it's it's quite a significant
piece of work
but whether in this instance the
addition of that to the other works
constitute that major reconstruction
adaptation etc is is obviously a matter
of judgment but often the new roof in
some of the cases that we discussed is
allied to other alterations knocking
down the walls new openings being
inserted into the building
and
an increase in height overall often
and
it's a summation of those different
elements that would lead me to the
conclusion in this case that it meets
your policy tests
but again that it doesn't matter for for
you as members obviously to to consider
that but those are the reasons in this
instance why we as officers have come to
the conclusion that we have
thank you councillor [ __ ]
no it's going back to the water issue um
i'd say that there wasn't water on site
because i noticed the photographs
yesterday there was lots of barrels
screwed up barrels as though they were
carrying water to the horses
are there any further questions
councillor jones
yeah i noticed that when we saw pictures
of the stable block itself
the roof came up over
the walls were here and the roof came
over it and then there was like a kind
of almost a veranda type thingy from
it's a measurements including that
under that roof or
but hopefully um if alice is still there
i think she will be if she can just
bring up the
slide again
you there ellis
yes
just you can go back um about four
slides i think hopefully it'll help
councillor jones in that if you can see
the just go back one more alice if you
would please you can see there that's
the existing structure with i think
that's the veranda that council jones is
is making reference to just go forward
one now at least please there would be
the retention of that veranda although
be albeit with the
additionally slightly increased pitch of
that roof over it that would be retained
as is or albeit in this instance rebuilt
with the slightly higher roof line
through there
hopefully that to that answers that
question
thank you are there any further
questions
no i'll open the floor for debate it's
there's going to be one
councillor foster thank you shall make a
start then yeah the volunteers
uh
for myself uh
many of you let me speak about greenbelt
development
in these meetings a lot and under the
meetings
and i've always been
against any development of the
agreement
in the green belt
but
this for me
i've tried to get to the bottom of the
local plan the policies we've got in
there around sdc one uh ss10 and ss9 and
taking advice we've had from offices
it's
it's the the number it seems to be
around policy stc one and that
major alterations adaptations and
reconstruction for me
and
you know
you look at it and in my own view just
my own view they don't look like uh it
doesn't look like major adaptations and
reconstruction you know we've got a 600
ml on the roof and the same openings and
it's all on one level so if we were
if we were minded to give
planning permission for a building like
this and we were to use the policy stc
one this would fit that policy this
would be the one that uh
that would fit
uh i understand all the concerns about
uh
protecting the openness uh the water and
the electricity but it's this what it
boils around this uh this this you see
one so
those are my comments chair thank you
thank you councillor heartson
thank you chair uh yeah i i um in
agreement with the council foster i
don't think there's a uh it is a major
alteration of the existing building
um and i think it would be committed
within the
boundaries that were set out in the
local plan
um and i think they've also um the
officers have covered
a lot of the mitigating circumstances in
the report that they've put forward so
i haven't got a problem with it
thank you councillor hall
yeah thank you my concern is the lack of
information regarding services whether
they are or
on to site it sounds like they may not
be
if there's water books being used and
if there's a generator currently being
used that's
that goes against it for me but the
other thing we've got a like
letter from the parish clerk of killer
marsh saying that they do not believe
that the proposed development meets the
mppf section 13 paragraph one three four
one three five one three six one four
three and one
four five so are they things that we
need to be taking into consideration as
well
thank you any other comment
councillor jones
yeah i think there's a concern that a
business owners run around horses
they're taking away the stables
fair enough
but surely at some point in the near
future we may be asked
to grant permission for another stable
block
thank you
councillor hancock then councillor hall
thank you chair um asia will be quite
surprised about this one because we
perfectly on the side i don't even have
any issues over it at all it makes
perfect sense to me um yeah i mean as
roger said earlier they uh the old one
was a two-story one which yeah that that
would massively breach it but for the
sake of 2-4 i really don't assume that
this would have any impact on openness
or or any problems at all i've got
absolutely no issue with this whatsoever
your counselor
yeah going back to the uh previous
planning applications i've even read
back to the 1999 ones and where you've
just stated it's been used as a business
in the 1999 planning application it
states that it must only be used by
family and family members so
if it's currently being used as a
business then is that not a breach of
current um
uh planning application is that another
issue
i don't know but it's just a thought
that's all
just raised and just come back on
particularly one one important point
that's been raised in respect to the
mppf
yes certainly the
the mppf you need to take that into
account in your your decision making but
as we've set out in the
report
it's an officer view that the policies
in your own local plan are
in compliance with the mppf and in that
respect you would be taking into account
the mppf in new consideration in the
consideration of your own planning
policies
in terms of the the issue about the the
business that council halls mentioned
i'm i'm not aware that there is a
business outside the the proper um
taking care of horses for the family on
the site but council is correct if that
was taking place then that would need a
planning application in its own right
but i'm not aware that that is the case
chair
just just finally on the the issues that
members
raise regarding services
if they're of particular concern to
members then you could control them
through the imposition of conditions
requiring
details of all those elements to be
submitted to and approved in writing by
the council to ensure that any need for
any additional pipe work or
routing of electricity or other services
could be um controlled to ensure that
all took place in an appropriate form
chair so if that was a particular
concern to members
and i've not provided the clarity that
you would have liked then you can belt
embraces that by adding conditions to
any approval you you may wish to to uh
grant the saturday again that'll be a
matter for yourselves i think they're
just the point i wanted to make sure but
particularly
you need to take into account the mppf
yes that's always the case
but often
particularly with your your up-to-date
local plan
those policies in the mppf have been
incorporated into the policies that you
have in the plan i certainly that's the
case in this instance
thank you councillor armitage
well i think adrian has
answered the question that i was going
to point out that
uh as regards the main services these
can be put in
and it can be
put in the application well the as a
condition
uh and preferably as it's in the green
belt they ought to be underground so
they're not seen
and also maybe a char uh a car charging
point
as well
councillor elliott and then i think i'm
going to round up oh
councillor fosters
thank you um yeah i i i said this
earlier and i've seen this over my years
on planning where we we give the
permissions to and i know we're looking
at this application but i know we've
seen this before where we've given
permission for a stable block to be
converted to a bungalow or a dwelling
and the next minute we've got another
application to build a stable block
now i don't know what else is on that
site whether there are buildings that
can be utilized for that and that's what
they're going to do
but is there something we can condition
where or do we just wait to throw it out
next time around because i'm i i think
this is going to be less intrusive than
most so i'm quite happy to go with
officer recommendation to grant it
but i sort of need to know that this
isn't just yet another way around
planning
um
around the planning authority and then
in another three months time six months
time we're going to end up with a can we
convert
this barn into these stables and so on
is there anything we can do to condition
that hadrian
a short answer question share is
you can't i don't believe you can
because it's it's a matter that would
lie in the future and there is no
certainty that an application would be
submitted but what i can advise members
is if
there is
an a need on site for further stables
that would be subject of an application
so you would have control over that
and
and what it's worth share i share
members
and concerns about this particular issue
and i i believe that if
um
the council wished to restrict
additional stables a building having
already been converted
that would be within a powers to do that
i can't guarantee ultimate success if
that was then challenged to appeal like
i'm never able to do that well i think
you would have
enough control over that to to take that
view so i don't think you would need to
condition that chair
um so hopefully that
i don't think necessarily gives casually
the answer he'd like but i think that
hopefully gives enough information on
which to thanks agent it doesn't in so
much as we yeah we can't we can't
control that at the moment we could
through a next application but i think
we've already been hoodwinked then you
know i'm quite happy to go along with
this
if it's going to be for a dwelling but
not the
you know we'll convert this to a
dwelling but we still need stables
it it i don't know if this is any um
consolation to members but i did ask
this question of the applicant when i
was personally on site and there is
another building already there which is
their intention should they need it to
use that for disabling of horses that's
that's already there so i have i've
already raised that question with the
applicant but but again
you've only got my word for it and i
can't predict the future that that would
be a matter for for application but
i assure members i can't predict the
future absolutely um but but certainly
and the council would have control over
any further application for stable so it
would be within your your powers to to
control that going forwards there won't
be any committed development that's
that's what i'm trying to say i suppose
if it's already a building there
it's not an additional building
for stabling
yes that's that's exactly the case
i sort of got that yeah
but i think that's something we we would
control by saying you know you've got an
adequate building you don't need to
build a new one
hopefully
uh thank you chair yeah i'll stay on the
same subject uh but first of all i'll
mention
that it's i have difficulty with uh
granting uh
permission for this sort of development
uh but at the same time we must make
decisions here that are defensible and
when we look at our policy it's very
very difficult to i find not this bike
when we look at policy and it's got to
ultimately standard appeal but going
back to uh
the points that council eliot mentioned
uh when it comes to giving permission on
this uh question for officers when it
comes to giving
permission for this is it possible
to put those restrictions in at this
stage rather than wait for the later
applications to come in so for example
we've got the stables that are there uh
we've mentioned that those stables could
be used to stables but those stables
could also be used as another house
you know uh and that's just around the
corner and it's even worse because we've
set a precedent giving them you know
with everything else you've spoken about
today so we've set a present on that
very site not just in the in northeast
derbyshire so i'd be interested in
knowing what restrictions were able to
put on giving this so some sort of
conditional
um
permission for this uh what restrictions
we can put on the site for those
existing stables they could be used as
stables but never used as another house
for example could we do that
and also restrictions on my other
concern which is second concern
and that's if somebody comes back if
they come that the applicants come back
later to alter the vigil
uh to extend slightly to uh put a
mezzanine floor in you know when they
want that little bit more for and they
come back without with a second
application on this on top of this one
so there's two questions there one is
the conversion can we add some sort of
restriction into those
conversion of those other stables
and the other one is
can we be really strict about what
permission they are getting for this
particular application and not you know
not welcome further
further application with another floor
thank you chair
just on the the first of those two
elements chair
it would be would be my view as i've
just mentioned to cancer elliot that i'm
i'm not aware there's any
mechanism that you
would be
lawful to restrict other
potential developments coming forward i
i don't believe i'm not aware of that
being the case
other than if the the applicant were to
sign a legal agreement to that effect
but even then there is the the
opportunity to to amend that coming
forward some subject to the time scales
that members are i'm sure aware of
i can only reiterate what i've said to
cancer elliot share that any application
to convert any other building on the
site
to a dwelling house
would require a separate
grant of planning consent so i believe
you would have the necessary
provisions in place to address that as
and when an application coming in and i
as i've said to cancer i can't predict
the future so i can't give any
guarantees that wouldn't be the case
but i don't believe members need to be
concerned about not having control over
that because even if you were to place a
control on it in terms of condition or
legal agreement there is always in
planning a mechanism to come back and
challenge that so i think you would have
the controls over that and
i i don't think members need to be
concerned about
that as a possibility without
restriction because it could be um it
could be challenged in any case as could
any um condition that you were to place
on on any permission granted as well
just in terms of the comment that um
made about coming back for what we would
normally term with section 73 you just
just had a section 73 before you again i
can't say that wouldn't be the case
but if that were to be the case then
again you would have the same controls
over
future applications and you would be
you'll be able to take a view on that
should an application be
submitted
so
i hope that's helpful
hopefully apply some clarity anyway
okay so we've had a nice lengthy debate
have we got anyone to propose a motion
council hancock
thank you all those in favor
share if i may just before
you formally take the vote is that with
the conditions in respect of services
yes yeah so that's that's water
electricity yeah yeah
thank you
okay everyone was over with the
condition yep
thank you favor was that uh unanimous
members
no um counselor hall
is there an abstention
against the council
the motion's been passed thank you
can move on to the final application
this afternoon
which is
application number
twenty one four zero zero five eight two
f l
we do have two speakers for this when we
get to that part of the proceedings
so i'm going to turn it over to adrian
once again
yes sir thank you chair again and alice
could um be on standby just in terms of
introduction chair this is an
application for the construction
of a dwelling house in connection with
the
matlock farm park that many members i'm
sure will be familiar with
the applicant is seeking consent to
construct a dwelling in association with
the management of the farm park and
it's a two stroke three three bedroom
two story dwelling in the location that
we'll see in a second
officers chair as members will see from
the report are not seeking to argue the
principle of a dwelling on the farm part
but in terms of the location and the
scale of the unit and its distance from
the other buildings officers are
concerned that
its
location in particular would contravene
the council's policies in respect of
protecting the countryside from
inappropriate development and also the
neighborhood plan policy which likewise
mirrors those so that's the the issue
that members may wish to
concentrate on if indeed you you support
the idea of the principle of a new
dwelling to support the farm park in
itself there aren't as far as officers
are concerned any technical reasons why
permission should be granted but on that
issue of the distance from the other
structures its isolation
and its scale officers are recommending
refusal in this case chair
if alice can can help me once again
please
the the wider site chair outlined in
beige as you can see on that
slide and you can just see the three
lines at the far
northwest top left an element of that
that beige
hexagon and that's roughly where the new
dwelling would be located right in the
the crease of the
between the trees and the road at the
top left of there you can see generally
the other buildings that form the
complex of the
farm part with the primary
access to the right top right of the the
beige area
thanks alice
and the the site outlined in red the
administrative boundary of derbyshire
dales is to the the left of the the
slide butting the the site
um where the application site is located
thanks alice
this is a slightly different orientation
with north now to the top left of the
the slide the application site is at the
bottom left so it's just
in the crease of the road and the
application site and you can see
the main complex of the the farm park
further to the
east southeast the the site where most
of the buildings are located certainly
where the entrance the main car parking
areas is located thanks alice
the application site in detail as you
can see it's in the crease of the road
which runs along the top of this slide
and the belt of trees which run along
the west hand side the prose dwelling is
the
colliding
square stroke oblong at the center of
the slide and the associated garden car
parking areas
associated with it shown on on that
slide thanks alice
it's a let's say two
three-bedroomed units the upper floors
two main bedrooms and then another room
identified as an office and then the
downstairs as you you would perhaps
expect a
dwelling of this this nature to be
addressed
thanks alice
and just
to recap a couple of the slides we saw
yesterday chair this is the area of hard
standing that's been formed to create
the
overflow parking area and the
application site
is at the
middle right of this this photograph so
it's right at the far end of the
hard surfaced area in the crease between
the the roadside hedge stroke trees on
the right hand side
and then the belt of trees that you can
see in the background so the dwelling
would be in that crease the far end of
this area of hard standing and then i
think alice if you can just go to the
next slide
taken from from roughly that area the
photograph previously was taken
the
area of hard standings straight ahead
just by the
area of grass that you can see there so
taken towards the right hand side here
you can just see that the belt of trees
again in the background that extends
to the
edge of the site and you can just make
out some of the buildings in the
distance that form the farm park they
are consented they're authorized but
it's the distance from those structures
and the other buildings comprising the
main built elements of the farm park
that have led officers to the conclusion
that the dwelling more closely
associated with existing buildings would
be a more appropriate solution in this
instance and i think there's one more
alice please
hey let's just take them from the
roadside chair again we saw this
yesterday but the roadside hedgerow you
can see there to the left and the start
of the belt of trees to the right hand
side
and the the dwelling would be i'm not
saying it would be directly through that
opening there but it would be through
that opening to the right
so again it gives us an idea of
um the structure and its location within
the landscape you can just make out the
tops of the the buildings
in the this middle center of that
photograph just above the the grass
stroke
and yes
stroke hedgerow i think that's it alice
would to just try one more
no that's the end of the chair thank you
thank you with two speakers this
afternoon on this application and the
first one is counselor carolyn renick
who called the application in are you
there carolyn
[Music]
should be joining us by soon
hello chuck i can uh i can see you oh
yeah
yeah
off you go karen in your three minutes
thank you thank you if you'd like to
call this in i've asked for this calling
as i'm lost to understand why this uh
plan hasn't been given approval matlab
farm park is the north east africa's
second biggest tourist attraction in
fact this business was originally set up
and the leader funding in partnership
with this council it's been hugely
successful winning the derbyshire
tractor of the year in 2022 and just one
prestigious daily mirror award gaining
national recognition and it's a former
portfolio holder tourism strategy i was
proud to start this district as a this
site is a district success story the
south now employs over 50 staff
thousands of visitors a year including
educational visits and has a successful
program supporting disadvantaged groups
and especially for disabled children
the south boundaries with the derbyshire
dales and the applicants have long-term
plans to extend the site campsite and
that also supports ours and dcc wider
tourism strategies to improve overnight
accommodation
there is no objection or issues from the
planning office in principle with all of
this and they agree there is a need for
a designated farm manager's
accommodation
and this has been a protracted and
lengthy uh consultation
this was actually submitted in july 21
and no objections were raised initially
by office regarding scale design through
the consultation and the extended
application so it's been surprised to me
to see this as rejection reason and in
fact no feedback's given to me on a site
visit recently where we could address
this as the applicant would be more than
happy to change the orientation uh
discuss any of those reasons i know the
application applicants would have no
problem also with any of the um
with with actually discussing the
materials or builds
as we planning to apologize for the
delay in sorting this because this is a
success story and it's a business that's
expanding despite the covered
restrictions that's had significant
impact on the sector so i'm keen to have
a fair hearing today to resolve this
swiftly the main issues seem to be
concerning the actual location of the
site
um and i'm not sure why it seems to fit
with all the relevant plumbing pluses
i've read in terms of gs1 gs6 d1 e10
tourism t2 t9 car parking ss1 ss9 lc6 sd
12 and wc6 which is the top of the
choice of development in the countryside
i believe the impasse is obviously where
the bills be um as they showed on the
diagram in the middle of the um you know
by the front entrance or in the middle
where all the other other buildings are
that's the middle of a very busy tourism
event space animal petting farms
and i think the reason for keeping that
slightly separate is to give anybody the
manager or family some private sectors
remain
and not to actually live literally in
the middle of a busy tourism attraction
with animal barns and event spaces
and more specifically to live in the
busy car park and so so we're just
talking about literally 200 so meters
difference in where the actual um
advocate would like it and i'd much
prefer to listen to their understanding
judgment and preference
uh as opposed to trying to move into the
middle evolving malay of the rest of the
park i don't believe this has a
significant impact on
escape it's a very busy site anyway
thank you carolyn are there any
questions
no
thank you very much carolyn
we've got another speaker this afternoon
and speaking on depart
apart
on behalf get the words out of the
applicant and it's mr doug morton if
you'd like to take the table
three minutes when you're ready
yes
good afternoon as councillor renick
outlines matlock farm park has won
multiple tourism awards this reflects
the hard work and commitment made to
make it such a fantastic destination for
those both visitors and residents alike
with a number of new facilities having
recently been constructed
it's disappointing the application is
recommended for refusal due to landscape
harm
through the ongoing dialogue for the
application no concerns were raised in
respect of design or scale with concerns
relating to its location only
we believe the officer report overstates
the level of harm for the landscape
the sighting of the manager's dwelling
has been carefully considered based on
the operational needs of the farm park
which is the sole reason for the
application
nearest the proposed manager's dwelling
is the ark used for animals who require
high level care and quarantine lambing
the big shed is also used for animals
with additional need along with the
storage of expensive machinery which is
also adjacent to the new play area which
is uncovered open-sided the proposed
manager's accommodation is orientated
southeast towards these buildings to
maximise natural surveillance the
western boundary to the farm park is by
far the most vulnerable it has low level
fencing which provides no security just
a boundary enclosure for animals so it's
prone to trespassing
with the sighting of the manager's
accommodation the employee the employee
will be closest to those animals most in
need of care and provide a physical
presence so massively improving security
without having to erect long runs of
fencing which itself could have a
significant landscape impact
the location of the proposed
accommodation is set well below jugger's
lane with a large bundle along the
boundary
immediately behind the proposed
accommodation is a mature belt of trees
and juggers lane also benefits from
trees with mature headrows with the
difference in levels only the second
story of the building would be visible
and be well screened by existing
vegetation proposed materials are
traditional they're designed simple so
complements existing materials used on
sites such as the shop and recently
constructed immunity facilities
it's also key that the manager's
accommodation provides a level of
residential immunity as the manager will
require days off it must be of
sufficient size for assembly for a
family with an office the chosen
location provides a suitable environment
for the manager alongside the functional
requirements of the building the
application when submitted offered an
obligation to tie the building to the
business which we are happy to agree
the need for the manager's accommodation
is not disputed the location of the
manager's accommodation is clearly
justified by the needs of the business
the building is modest of simple
traditional
30 seconds remain set lower than
jagger's lane and well screened any
limited harm to the landscape is clearly
outweighed by the benefits to the rural
economy for the award-winning matlock
farm park and we respectfully request
that council support the proposal and
approve the application
thank you are there any questions
councillor foster than councillor elliot
thank you chair uh thanks mr moulton
council poster um
my question is specifically around our
policy uh lc6 and uh perhaps more detail
if you please on uh the essential needs
element so what exactly are the needs of
the uh the overseer the manager that
would have to look at it currently
there's nobody looking after these uh
these animals
uh and
so
what i'm asking is are the animals being
bred is it for animals that are ill is
it risk from crime so what exactly is
the needs of the animals
currently the site
um
so obviously by having someone on site
you've got an instant response to
anything that comes up a link to that
they have our backers high leave animals
laming in the planning statement which i
haven't known all the facts i think it's
in the committee of what actually sets
out the range of animals and which ones
would like to specifically need to
actually it's actually it's that level
of care what's required particularly at
certain points of the season to do the
animal breeding and then link to that is
obviously on-site presence particularly
on that boundary it's very open
because the whole point of that part is
the essence is you come into the main
entrance and it's quite it's quite
constrained in there i mean
this is
um
thanks mr moulton one for the question
but i'm happy to
search i'll go now yeah uh questions
around uh the legal agreement that would
be required by officers for your
for your uh your clients to sign so i'm
guessing they've got no intention
you'll be able to they've got no
intention to sell the property and
they'd be happy to sign that legal
agreement that's required
[Music]
thank you
thank you chad i shouldn't let my
colleague goats has been
tying the accommodation to the business
um
[ __ ] uh council foster's asked that
and and you've provided an answer i
wondered if you could um furnish me with
any detail on uh on ap 11 which is the
design of the building and give us a bit
of a clue as to what they're wanting to
um
and we always believed that that was
being acceptable and it was only because
only when we sort of got to the uh
officer report that the issues around
sort of materials and scale
was sort of raised towards because like
i say we always thought we thought the
the planning office problem was with the
local actual location society of the
dwelling rather than how it looked like
or escaped
so
you know we think it's a suitable design
response or a modest dwelling for a
manager's accommodation suits which is
its backdrop really
you know there's good trees
providing good enclosures to the site
where we've been chosen to be sighted
but obviously you know design's
important and that's reflected
facilities
yeah i i can see why you'd have an issue
with needing somebody to be on site i
don't have a great deal of issue with
that and our
planning officers i'm fairly confident
would with it being built brand new and
into the green belt and so i mean thank
you thank you for that i would like to
see my can come back to adrian again i'd
like to have seen a stone room i know
we've had
an issue not very far away from there
with the entire thing with stone and
stone slate roofs and the rest of it
just to keep it in keeping with the with
that development so yeah thank you very
much
charlotte councillor foster speak so
good clean future
thank you
no you've got one more councillor house
yep
hello you're right
right on page 43 and it's 7.26 you know
you talk about the dwelling it's going
to be for the manager
and obviously in that paragraph it knows
that there is no an unauthorized static
caravan on site
so is this manager going to be is he
doing the security of the site at the
moment or is
the dwelling going to be
for whoever's doing the security on the
site
i mean obviously
i the only
yes okay thank you
thank you any further questions
thank you very much if you'd like to
take a seat
are there any questions for adrian
councillor elliot council foster
thank you chair adrian could you just
expand on this one for me i'm looking at
seven five it's saying whilst policy wc5
doesn't link the consideration of
workers accommodation it does support
visitor and tourism development and that
was the policy i was looking at on the
i've highlighted it wc5
and i asked the question
which actually refers to sdc12 about
high quality design and place making and
i'd like to see that if we if it's going
to go through and if we're going to
allow it it to be built up with all the
natural materials that would be in
keeping with
where that's going to get built
the um
issue on that chair
my understanding is that the the
dwelling would be constructed of stone
but not with a stone slate roof
if that was a particular issue for
members then you could
control that of course bearing in mind
you've heard what mr moulton's said on
that officers don't
necessarily have any notwithstanding the
point that council rausch has mentioned
which is referred to in the report
officers don't as i say aren't seeking
to argue
there isn't the need for a dwelling
house is just in terms of the discussion
it's the location of it away from those
other structures it's it's relative
isolation and its impact on the
landscape you know the issue
as um mr moulton's invited you to
consider is in effect if you feel there
is a landscape harm how much harm is
that and if there is that harm do you
feel that the need of the business
outweighs that time and that that's
fundamentally the issue before you if
you were particularly concerned about
elements of the design then i believe
you could control that through condition
if they were the the deal breaker
it was for me adrian because as you
rightly say it is
shall we say out in the middle of
nowhere i would want to see it screened
and built with the proper materials that
are in keeping with what surrounds it i
know we've had this situation not not so
far away and myself and the chair
and
so yeah
landscape keratin character for me was
it so if if we're minded to let it go
through
i think it's essentially condition that
through yourself to screen it and so on
well just in terms of that chair bearing
in mind what you've heard about the the
issue about the location
the discussion that has been about
viewing the site
a screening of it would probably negate
those those benefits i would i would
guard you against it to me if you want
to screen something it says yes there's
something fundamentally wrong with it if
you want to stop somebody seeing it so
there is already the backdrop of the the
trees to the west northwest and the
hedgerow along the roads there is an
element of softening already yeah i've
seen that to adrian i just wondered
whether it would be
pertinent for us to put more of that
type of
natural screen in it
you could certainly condition the
requirement for additional landscaping
on site or around the boundary if you
felt that was going to be
important but i said i would guard
against
wanting to screen it because it just
suggests maybe i'll pick the wrong word
agent maybe some tree plants some
softening yeah
thank you
just to point jim to one point of
clarification the site doesn't lie
within the green belt it just within a
countryside location
councillor foster uh thank you chair uh
two questions uh first one is when we
look at uh policy lc6 uh number two
uh any proposal for an occupational
drawing subject to be subject to plenty
obligations to tie the dwell into the
adjacent land and buildings how robust
these legal agreements
uh that can be written up to tie that
building to the business
that's the first question we just had
the discussion in respect to the stable
so um nothing in planning can't be
challenged i'm sure members are aware of
that but if and you've heard mr moulton
say there would be no objection to tying
any permission to i presume the
operation of the the farm park
if a legal agreement is signed that
they're robust to legal documents and
there needs to be
a period of at least five years before
that can unilaterally be challenged by
the
by the um in this case the applicant so
it would last for at least five years
and then it would be subject of formal
request to the council so again members
would have control over a new quest from
that um
five years would be the minimum but i
can't say that it would be indefinitely
that that would be the case but you've
heard what mr moulton said and i'm sure
that's a genuine commitment
we often use these sorts of things in
respect of agricultural workers
dwellings and we have in the past or
similar so it's not an unusual
tool to use to specifically if
you're saying that the the reason for
giving permission is for the farm part
then it would be wholly appropriate to
have such an agreement in this case
thank you for that second one was about
the same point that you mentioned about
that uh council elite mentioned about
the trees that i do know the site
there's already trees and hedgerow
screen in that i'd be uh my worries
would be and i'd like your comments on
on my concerns uh about providing
further uh covering covering around that
uh that property where it's proposed
because it seems like the whole idea of
having having that building them in the
first place is to be able to oversee the
farm to provide security to look at the
animals so that then my concerns about
further screening could you comment on
those at all
i don't really reiterate what i said to
cancer early i think if you're trying to
blanket a building out it just suggests
there's some some wider issues that are
perhaps at play you could certainly
condition the landscape you seem to
soften it to supplement what there is
and certainly from the roadside i think
as
a more deeper screen would be perhaps
appropriate if you felt that was
necessary but if if you're saying that
the if committee took the view that the
building is is necessary for the farm
for the reason set out and that's as in
effect overriding all other issues then
i think it would be appropriate for you
to require some softening but i i don't
think i think a screen would negate some
of that reasoning behind
and grant information in this location
for a dwelling
counselor hall thank you yeah i just
wanted to ask i know it's been
touched upon with the uh static
unauthorized uh static caravan were
reminded if we are minded to grant
permission for this would the static
caravan be removed is that something
you've been in discussion with the owner
about
the the um
location of the caravan is something
that officers have noted and we have
raised the question with the applicant's
agent about why not put a
dwelling house on that location which is
closer to the farm
buildings and the other structures
comprising the entrance the farm part
the car parking the the adjoining
agricultural buildings
we've been
asked to consider the application on its
merits that is not deemed to be an
appropriate location for the dwelling
so getting back to the point the council
raised chair the
mobile home is unauthorized
and it should be removed in any case
unless consent is granted otherwise but
i would certainly expect without the
need to
otherwise require it if you did grant
permission i would expect the the mobile
home to be removed or else it certainly
would be my view that the council should
be seeking to use its powers to secure
its removal
yeah
council
yeah my concern was that if we were to
grant permission would they then put a
planning application in for the mobile
home as well
oh i don't know
i can't guarantee that wouldn't be the
case but i i would expect from what
you've heard this afternoon that the
dwelling would negate the need for any
other on-site 24-hour accommodation and
i would expect the mobile home to be
removed
and for well fourth wave
okay thank you council elliott then
councillor armitage adrian this is this
is one that i'm i'm hoping you can
answer for me and it is sort of around
the development part of it if you if if
we were asked to build um
a dwelling on a farm am i right in
saying they have to have a certain
head of cattle or sheep or whatever to
allow a workers accommodation to be
built
that's how it used to work out anyway
is that still the case that's set out in
in policy lc6 it would that would be the
functional need and historically would
also be looking for a financial
need on a on any business and as as here
you would expect a functional financial
need to justify a dwelling the
policy set up now is
is wider than it was previously it was
restricted more
primarily just haven't cultural work
done whereas now this rural business
need that just has come into national
policy which is why in this instance
officers taking the view that this would
satisfy that there'll be a need for
another dwelling on this
i'm not saying farmholding because it's
not on this side that's right and that's
that's the case but we are of the view
that from all that you've heard again
this afternoon or that we know of that
there is that
functional and financial need that that
even now some inspectors heart back to
to
seem to justify dwellings in similar
situations such as this yeah thank you
to that answers the question yeah he
does thank you
councillor armitage
uh thank you chair
uh it's been mentioned about the
[Music]
putting trees and whatever around it to
soften it
but
what i've been writing saying that we're
looking at something called security
and that was one of the reasons
why this building was going to be put up
uh
if we go against and start planting
trees around it
the chap won't be able to see what's
going on on site do you think
you would agree on that
as as discussed with them cast the
foster cash elliot country yes i think
that would be a very valid point if
you're wanting the the dwelling on the
site for those reasons to to screen it
with trees would negate one of those
functional requirements if you like
through the chair i did say that you
know i picked the wrong word it wasn't
screaming as much as softening and i'm
not talking about putting a barricade
round of dwelling i'm talking about
putting hedge rows and trees on the
boundaries
i agree with softening of the front of
the building but yeah it's a delineation
isn't it are there any further questions
for the officer
no okay i'll open the floor for debate
councillor liggett then councillor
foster then councillor hancock
i'm just going to say i'm in complete
agreement with the councillor renick um
i've
i've spent years and years and years in
that area um and i just don't believe
for a minute that it
could harm the landscape i mean the
actual farm park is huge anybody that
knows it it is like a great big factory
anyway so a little stone cottage in the
corner is not going to make a lot of
difference
thank you
thank you councillor foster thank you
chair yeah um yeah for myself first of
all with regards to this actual business
we've got to be very supportive of local
business
businesses uh like this especially ones
that provide
so much to the community matlab farm
park brings a lot of revenue into our
district brings a lot of business rates
it provides a lot of employment for
local people
uh and it's a business for me that's got
true community value it really has so
that's some of you on the actual
business when it comes to
the responses that we've had all the
consultation responses have come back
without objections including a local
ward member
and uh also the pirate local parish
council so this all seems to me revolve
around the actual needs of the business
which is why i asked mr moulton that
first question now under lc six uh for
me if we accept that this rural business
has those essential needs then we should
be giving permission
uh for this new new dwelling and i think
officers are in uh in agreement with
that
i'm happy that those essential needs are
our true needs so that's the first one
for me
then on page 39 7.8
uh without me reading it out but 7.8
that paragraph there
explains that the mppf
uh
is in agreement with with this sort of
development so we've got that we've got
lc6
uh so then for me it's much like it's
said in the in the conclusion uh from
officers uh it's about balancing the
needs
of this business which they've stated
with the harm caused by the character to
the landscape as i'm i'll happily
happily be corrected by officers on this
but that's what it seems that i'm being
asked to decide yeah
so for me and any building uh it's not
in the greenbelt but it is in the
countryside any building is going to
cause harm to that landscape any
building so it's going to cause harm
regardless wherever it is and for me
it's all about whether it's significant
harm now my own view is that it is harm
but it's not significant
and because of that i feel that the
needs of the business and support of
this local business this tourism
outweighs
the needs
outweighs the harm and it is harmful
it's not significant harm so that's what
i'd like i'd like to say
um
so that seems to be the crux of the
matter lc6 and uh the planning framework
uh there is no significant harm and i'm
happy where it's actually been proposed
uh i'm not a fan of screening or any
softening to the front but i'd support
uh perhaps further further trees or
further shrubbery or hedgerow
to the existing
barrier behind
thank you chair
thank you councillor hancock
thank you chair
this one again to me was a bit of a
no-brainer and it's rare i agree with
adrian it's even rarer that i agree with
carolyn but i do want this one um
it is i mean the business needs it but
picking up on everything that marx just
said which i do agree with i think as
well one of the key points is we've got
to bear in mind that there is a family
of the worker here so this site is
perfect because it's giving them the
privacy
and the the freedom to live their lives
so so i i would actually um agree with
agree with the comments we've had so far
and and go against officer's
recommendations and support it
okay are there any
other comments to be made
no
have i got someone to put motion on
council earlier i will pull the motion
forward that would go against officers
recommendation
uh and site ss1 for sustainable
development lc6 as as a need for the
agricultural forestry and occupational
dwelling in the countryside
and
i will leave it with adrian
if possible um i did mention about being
built in stone and being built with all
the local
um
you using the local stone and if we can
do stone roof if we can do the stone
slate roof then i'd like to see that
and again as mark said the uh you know
as i've stated i don't want it hemmed in
but i would still like to see
softening with trees and hedgerows on
the boundaries
for
that screen in word
do you want to also include the thai
condition oh without a doubt that was
the first thing i asked
of mr moulton yeah that it is tied to
the business and it's not to be sold as
a separate dwelling
councillor foster
uh thanks chair uh yeah i'm happy to
second uh that proposal uh i'd like if
you talk with the commission
[Music]
officers on the
on on the actual roof materials yeah
because i know uh
i don't know if stone slates stone roofs
are a common place around there or
generally recommended so i'd happily
advise advice on that first before we
that's why i said well i'll go along
with it if we can do it i'd rather do it
we have the same thing on an application
a couple of months right same thing
thank you
okay we've got a motion in place and a
second
all those in favor
before we do that can we absolutely
clear then on the motion so that is to
approve planning permission against
officer recommendations
uh quoting really policies ss1 lc6
and then also relating to the issues
here about
the possible stone roof whether that
could be explored with officers and then
also the issues about the softening of
the landscape impact
also wc5 allen wc5 just
for me add to that check
just in terms of the materials it's
proposed that the
building would be natural stone
with a natural slate roof
and
our stance as officers would be then in
general terms a slate roof in this
location would be appropriate
so unless um
an actual stone
slate roof
is a
and if i couldn't and just ask cher that
if members of money to grand consent
that
appropriate and necessary conditions are
delegated to myself they would include
landscaping use of appropriate materials
and probably goes a little further than
that probably would like to control
things like levels just just for the
sake of clarity and of course be a 106
agreement that that could be either a
unilateral agreement or a
assigned
undertaking side of the council as well
and we'll take legal advice on that that
may be a unilateral undertaking which
serves the same purpose may be
sufficient in this case happy with all
those chair and if adrian can get the
level if you're looking at the levels if
it can be
sunk in a bit i mean given that i know
it's a really low water table up there
uh if it can be sunk down a bit then
happy days we'll have some of that as
well
councillor foster than councillor hall
when it comes to the to the actual
motion itself when it comes to the
materials of the property i'd be quite
happy with reconstituted stone as well i
think it doesn't have to be full natural
stone i think that's that'd be accepted
no yeah no
actually it's a matter for for you as as
members chair of course take your advice
on that but we would normally
look for natural zone i believe that's
been offered in this case i don't think
that would be detrimental and and in the
proposal if we include my earlier
comments which i made in the debates
about there being no significant harm
that's acceptable
counselor hall
i would just concerned about the static
home do we need to tie that in at all as
well or is that i think that's a
different application i don't think we i
don't think you're in jeopardy from that
chair we will follow that up with the
applicants and i believe it should be
it's inappropriate in that location in
my view and unless an application is
submitted for it we will we'll see the
applicant's cooperation getting it
getting removed
okay
okay so we've now got the motion
proposed and seconded
sorry can i suggest that as this is a
motion against officer recommendations
that you take a roll call fine
i'm happy with that
okay counselor armitage
councilor cooper
councillor elliot
councillor foster
for
councillor hall for
councillor hancock for
counselor hearts on for
councillor liggett for
councillor jones for all
councillor powell
councillor ross
and councillor roth oh
that's unanimous chair emotions passed
thank you
moving on to item eight planning appeals
yep if
no one's got any questions about them
nope that's fine if we just move them
all in favor
thank you
just not your head
i've no matters of urgency otherwise i
would like to thank councillor powell
for stepping into the breach whilst i
was away
really appreciate that thank you very
much
item 10 exclusion of the public
[Laughter]
and we can now remove the live feed
sorry just to be pedantic would you be
able to actually move the specific
motion thanks
exclusion to the public that the public
be excluded from the meeting during the
discussion of the following item
business to avoid the disclosure to them
of exempt information as defined in
paragraphs two and five of part one of
the schedule 12a to the local government
act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2008
thank you
thank you
you